wir sind zurück und kommen jetzt zu dem
Thema von Susanne Schröder die hat
nämlich gerade eine Veranstaltung gehabt
wo auch Boris Palma da war und seitdem
erleben sie kann man es überhaupt noch
ein Shitstorm nennen oder muss man schon
viel weitergehen ja man man muss ganz
klar benennen es ist eine
Rufmordkampagne die dagegen mich
gefahren wird und zwar
deutschlandweit haben sich da jetzt
Leute angeschlossen die wohl entdeckt
haben wie schön es ist mal nachzutreten
es begann aber schon vor der Konferenz
muss ich sagen die Konferenz vielleicht
mal zum zur Information war eine
Konferenz die die gingen mit dem Titel
Migration Steuern Pluralität gestalten
da ging es um das Gesamtpaket von
Einwanderungsgesellschaft
Fachkräftemangel warum gelingt es so
schlecht Fachkräfte zu bekommen
bildungsmäßig ihre was ähm wie sieht es
in den Schulen aus was kann man dagegen
machen dass es besser läuft das auch
Kinder mit migrantischen Hintergrund
mehr Schulabschlüsse machen es ging
natürlich auch um fl Flüchtlinge und
darum was man tun kann das nicht so
viele im Mittelmeer ertrinken und es
ging auch ein Parallelgesellschaften
also vier große Blöcke letztendlich
schon im Vorfeld gab es Aktivisten auch
unter den Studenten aber nicht nur die
gesagt haben die die Konferenz ist
rechtspopulistisch weil so der AStA der
Begriff des Steuerns ein
rechtspopulistischer Begriff sein das
muss man sich mal überlegen Konferenz
war übrigens hochrangig besetzt von
führenden Wissenschaftlern im Bereich
Migration Leuten aus der Bundesagentur
für Arbeit in Kooperation mit der Herr
die Stiftung und so weiter und so fort
und also es gab vor der Konferenz eine
große Kampagne und während der Konferenz
haben sich Aktivisten vor dem Gebäude
versammelt und haben alle als Nazis
beschäftigt die reingegangen sind so und
das war ziemlicher Terror die ganze Zeit
auch Sie also alle nicht nur einmal war
gar nicht da der Palma kam am Schluss zu
seinem Vortrag das hat gar keine
mitgekriegt der ist diesem brüllenden
Mopf in die Arme gelaufen und hat dann
muss ich sagen wirklich vollkommen
inadäquat reagiert deshalb jede
Stöckchen gesprungen dass man im
hingehalten hat und hat sich dann dazu
Äußerungen hinreißen lassen die ich auch
nicht akzeptiere mich davon distanziert
auch
das war das eine aber dann ist Palmers
Auftritt sozusagen genommen worden als
Ausgangspunkt noch mal nachzuhaken nicht
nur Palma zu skandalisieren sondern zu
sagen die ganze Konferenz und mein
Forschungszentrum globaler Islam sei
schon immer rechtspopulistisch gewesen
immer islamfeindlich gewesen ich hätte
schon immer problematische Äußerungen
getätigt bzw Leute eingeladen die
problematisch und rechts populistisch
waren unter anderem haben mit
abgesammelt und auch mit Mann so ach mit
Mann so ist gerade ausgezeichnet worden
mit dem bundesverdienst
zum Beispiel ja und das waren sozusagen
die Belege weshalb ich rechts Populist
sei weil ich unter anderem auch mit Mann
so einlade also es war hochgradig absurd
aber mittlerweile muss man sich schon
fragen wer sich da alles jetzt in dieser
Gruppe derjenigen die mal nach treten
zusammengefunden hat jetzt gerade in
Interview gelesen von einem
ethnologieprofessor an einer deutschen
Universität der sagt ich wäre wohl der
Meinung dass nur weiße bestimmende nur
weiße definieren dürften was Rassismus
oder das weiße definieren könnten was
rassismus ist da muss ich sagen ein
deutscher Professor sagt tatsächlich
dass eine wissenschaftliche Definition
von der Hautfarbe abhängt da habe ich
doch dann doch ein deutliches Gefühl von
fremdschämen muss ich sagen na ähnlichen
Richtung haben sich andere Kollegen aus
wissenschaftlichen Vereinigungen
artikuliert eine große Gruppe hat sich
gleich positioniert als Kampftruppe
gegen Rassismus wo er Rassismus ein bin
auch gegen Rassismus aber rassismus ist
sozusagen ein riesen Begriff der alles
und jedes umfasst völlig unspezifisch
geworden und mit solchen Kampfbegriffen
operieren ja nicht nur Wissenschaftler
aus einem bestimmten wirken Umfeld
sondern das Problem haben wir ja auch in
der gesamten im gesamten Kulturbetrieb
das haben wir in den Medien und das
haben wir in Teilen der Politik dass
eine
eine einzige Ideologie als moralisch
legitim gehandelt wird alles was ein
anderen Aspekt reinbringt in zum
Beispiel die Migrationsdebatte wird
automatisch als rassistisch und
rechtspopulistisch abgelehnt und dann
haben wir das Problem das beispielsweise
über Schattenseiten der Migration die
ist ja auch gibt ja nicht nur positive
Seiten gibt es auch aber es gibt auch
Schattenseiten die hatten sollten wir
meiner Meinung nach dringend behandeln
damit sie gelöst werden aber wer sie
benennt gilt automatisch als Rassist wir
haben am Anfang ihrer These gesagt dass
sie jetzt ein Rufmord gegen sie also
nicht nur schützt haben sondern Rufmord
und sie haben auch das fand ich in der
Welt haben sie ja auch ganz klar auch
noch gesagt in einem Zitat das ist ja
auch wirklich was gerade passiert nicht
mehr geht haben sie noch Angst um ihren
Job oder ist das Berufliche Konsequenz
muss man nicht befürchten nein darüber
habe ich keine Angst ich habe aber Angst
in meinen Forschungszentrum weil es
verschiedentlich die Forderung erhoben
wurde man möge doch mal über denken ob
man das weiter dulden könne und das war
sozusagen die Aufforderung natürlich
auch an die entsprechenden
Verantwortlichen und da finde ich muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen dass das ist
schon wirklich der Hammer auch im
Vorfeld gab es schon so lange betreiben
sie es Forschungszentrum heute ich also
ich bin in Frankfurt seit 2008 weil
vorher in im bayerischen Passau und seit
15 Jahren sind jetzt schon
ganz genau und seitdem habe ich einen
starken islam-schwerpunkt habe für viele
muslimische prominenten zum Doktor
betreut und die sind in ihrer
Heimatländer zurückgegangen haben haben
wir jetzt tolle Karrieren gemacht ja wir
haben immer mit vor allem mit
ausländischen jungen Leuten
zusammengearbeitet die Sprach- und
kulturkompetent in ihren Heimatländern
waren und haben immer ein hochgradig
internationales Team gehabt
ich würde mal sagen ich habe mehr
Muslime promoviert als diejenigen die
jetzt ich sei eine antimotrimische
Rassistin
fragen wir jemanden
auf in Frankfurt studiert
was sagst du zu dem Vorfall also das ist
ein Prozess der schon lange stattfindet
schon immer hatte Frau Schröter viele
Kritiker und das hat einfach damit zu
tun dass seit vielen Jahren
ja ja es gab ja schon immer
Demonstrationen und ich erinnere mich
auch mal das eine Konferenz nicht
stattfinden konnte das
Sicherheitsgründen dann ich glaube das
war bei der Polizei Gewerkschaft sehr
reiner sind genau eingeladen war der
auch versucht wird als rechts in der
Ecke zu tun eingeladen wurde war so
sicherheitsgrün nicht mehr möglich es
waren ich glaube es wurde so viele
Demonstration aufgerufen und weil man
nicht wusste wie linksex extrem die
Personen sind hat man das lieber aus
Sicherheitsgründen dann abgesagt und da
sieht man wie weit das geht es ist schon
seit langem so das versucht wird das nur
eine Welt an sich die gute ist
und vor allem die Weltansicht wo man
sich kritisch befasst mit Themen wie dem
politischen Islam wie es Frau Schröter
tut und Frau Schröter ist eine der
renommiertesten Islamforscher die wir in
Deutschland haben und ich glaube niemand
kennt sich so gut mit Islamismus außen
hat so die die ganzen Strukturen
erforscht wie Frau Schröter es hat ja
und das ist natürlich für Leute die
diese eine Weltansicht haben gefundenes
Fressen und ist das ist alles rechts für
die also wenn es umso auch um Migration
allgemein geht Dinge zu benennen und zu
kritisieren aber um hier heute in
Grauzone zu sprechen wir haben oder
nicht draußen aber um nicht alles
schwarz weiß man wir haben einmal Ihren
Fall als renommierte Professorin und
dann haben wir ja aber der das dann die
Konferenz überdeckt hat das passiert ja
oft dass irgendwas Konferenzen überdeckt
oder man macht nur Konferenzen plötzlich
sind AFD Politiker da und dann man weiß
ja wie es funktioniert ähm was sagst du
denn zu dem Vorfall von Herr Palma ja
der Vater von Palma er hat das
provoziert wie Frau Schulter schon sagte
er ist in dieser Motte rein gerannt
aber auch da und also erstmal muss ich
sagen die Konferenz dieser Konferenz war
gar nichts rassistisch das war eine ganz
normale Konferenz wo man sich kritisch
mit Dingen auseinandergesetzt hat und
vor allem auch darüber geredet hat wie
man verhindert dass Menschen sterben im
Mittelmeer ja und Boris Palmer ist sehr
spät gekommen ist in dieser Meute
reingerannt hat auch provoziert und hat
dann auch dazu gestanden dieses Wort
mega zu sagen auch gegenüber von
jemanden der eine schwarze Hautfarbe
hatte aber warum macht
wir kennen alle Herr Palmer als
Provokateur und ich glaube viele lieben
auch Palme als Provokation
und das auch im guten Sinne viel
geleistet muss man sagen ja er ist
bekannt für sein Klartext im guten Sinne
und ähm hier ist er halt über eine
Grenze hat er überschritten und ich bin
fest davon überzeugt auch deshalb haben
wir keinen Rassist ist
das was er gesagt hat ging natürlich gar
nicht und das muss man auch so benennen
und er hat sich selbst auch davon
distanziert und hat sich ja auch
psychologische Hilfe geholt und ich
finde das auch sehr glaubwürdig von ihm
tatsächlich dass er das eingesehen hat
und was jetzt bei Frau Schulter passiert
ist das intolerante Menschen sei es
jetzt Wissenschaftler die in diesem Buch
Wahnsinn andere Meinung nicht mehr
akzeptieren die instrumentalisieren das
jetzt und versuchen halt Frau Schröter
loszuwerden auch von Seiten halt von
Ministerien welches richtig verstanden
hat es geht um ihre Forschungszentrum
dass man sich dort auch beschwert also
da habe ich jetzt da kann ich gar nicht
nein es gibt es gibt die Forderung von
Wissenschaftlern also zum Beispiel von
einem Bayreuther Exzellenzcluster die
sind auch von die sind auch schon vor
der Konferenz sind auch schon solche
Forderungen erhoben worden man möge doch
mal unseren Laden schließen ähm weil da
nur Anti muslimischer Rassismus und
ähnliches
Wirtschaft haben offensichtlich in
diesem Land wir machen einmal eine
Abkürzung genau zu den Medien ich wollte
noch einen ja gerne wichtigen Satz dazu
sagen glaube ich dass es wichtig ist für
mich geht die Sache über diesen Fall
hinaus wäre Frau Professor Schröter
virologin und hätte Zweifel an den
covid-maßnahmen geäußert wäre ihr genau
dasselbe passiert wäre sie
klimaforscherin und hätte Zweifel an den
sogenannten kipppunkten das alles nur
noch das schon zu spät ist für alles es
würde genauso gehen wie jetzt das
Islamwissenschaftlerin und und
Ethnologin die Wissenschaft in
Deutschland zerstört sich selbst denn
Wissenschaft bedeutet Zweifel
Wissenschaft bedeutet Skepsis
Wissenschaft bedeutet Diskurs und all
das wird abgeschafft im Sinne einer
ideologischen Ausrichtung und deswegen
geht das weit über Ihren Fall hinaus und
absolut und gibt uns wirklich
anders zu Besorgnis sein völlig möchten
dass diesem Grund habe ich mit anderen
Kollegen zusammen vor 2020 das
netzwerkwissenschaftsfreiheit gegründet
da sind wir dachten erstes sind alles
nur Geisteswissenschaftler weil die
Geisteswissenschaften besonders darunter
leiden nein nein wir haben aus allen
Disziplinen Naturwissenschaften Medizin
wir haben überall mittlerweile 740 744
Professoren die sich da angeschlossen
haben weil in ihren Bereichen die
Wissenschaftsfreiheit auch gefährdet ist
und weil wir dokumentieren Fälle da gibt
es ordentlich viele mittlerweile und wir
versuchen auch die
Betroffenen zu unterstützen aber was
reflexartig hat dieses Netzwerk den
Stempel rechts bekommen wundert keinen
weil alles kriegt den Stempel rechts was
eine bestimmten wirkengruppe nicht passt
übrigens würde ich sagen das ist eine
woke linke und das möchte ich auch
konkret abgegrenzt haben von aufrechten
Sozialdemokraten oder von säkularen
Grünen oder anderen linken die ich
selber sehr schätze die selbst entsetzt
sind über diesen Kurs der da genommen
wird wurden sie abgezockt oder
reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
ihren
falls Sie